I think we're gonna touch a topic that I
touched somewhat here in the past but
there are just too many games that in
the tournament right now in vacancy in
Netherland one of the strongest
tournament in the world starting the
year that have this topic and our topic
is well I will king and everything
that's happening well around the king
mainly well forgetting to have pieces
around the king and the consequences of
that then and actually most of the games
there's one game I thought reasonable in
the a group which is where a union in a
Kimora and Kawana Kuryakin many of the
best players in the world are playing
and actually a bit more games in the B
section which is strong enough you know
there's some strong to very strong
grandmasters there but yet not a elite
tournament so we will see several
examples and that's other games like one
game that I'm just thinking now is the
fourth game in the World Championship
between an and antu Paulo
maybe if we will finish quickly with
many of those examples it's quite
instructive on how suddenly a none
sacrifice on the kingside well all the
pile of pieces were on the Queen side
but let's start so we have the young
international master Benjamin Bach
playing against another young player
world champion under 20 you young guy
from China so I mean both of them are
under 20 I think you is like 20 and
Benjamin Bach like 18 if I'm not
mistaken so really young pleasant the
playing in the B section the winner of
the B section gets to play in the a
section so that's quite I mean other
than the financial reward that's a
really big thing okay
the game in itself is a bit less
interesting maybe one can go quickly
with some sort of Sicilian
okay white got the pawn
usually we white doesn't manage to get
the pawn from c2 to c4 because black
play early 96 and forcing white to go 93
but okay we are basically getting some
sort of a hedgehog structure but it's
it's a bit less positional because white
f-pawn indicates that well is going to
make effort at least to attack but like
I said we were going to skip this or
move fast by the way this this move is
important because what what's going to
happen after if I just for one minute we
can spend on this position what's
happening after e5
taketake okay white will take which
night is hanging excellent job excellent
job so this is actually a good move and
it's not just the night very good
everything on the d file is hanging okay
that that seems quite quite impressive
on those something like this Pataki
maybe Bishop d6 Knight f3 very normal
moving the knight from the D file and E
5 now so okay g6 blocking ultra blocking
this diagonal okay but this is where we
really gonna start our discussion you
know I have shown here not once and
today this will be our main topic only
topic just to look at the square around
a king like black does have some
defenders well the book I always says
books are quite bad defenders because
how is the rukon dat is in the square
but what can you really defend I mean
okay it's defending II sticks but they
were cannot defend a seven g seven eight
seven so the you can really defend the
background okay not much more usually so
black really has two pieces that are
guarding his king or maybe two and a
half pieces you know like the knight
that's obviously controlling some
squares and the bishop but white can
have many many pieces let's take this
beautiful arrows take those beautiful
arrows away but white potentially has a
lot of pieces that are at least aiming
to this side of the board
right I mean the night is already there
the Queen is aiming the rook is there
the bishop is aiming this bishop this
bishop is a big piece but it's blocked
but technically the bishop is aiming
only this night is far away and even
this hook is somewhere in that area
those that those are big things so one
of most natural moves for white in this
position is going to be dramatic sounds
man
I'm going to be 93 is okay the night is
under attack you want to go back I think
I think black will play this move and
make effort to put a knight on e5 and
like black will be very comfortable I
mean this night in that grade blockading
square doesn't look bad if I that that's
the thing like everything is aiming at
that direction
remember our topic today is going to be
the king the king the king and pieces
around the king like how all the time we
should keep some kind of balance in our
head some kind of a ratio between
potential pieces that can attack how
many defenders we have because those
those really strong players like really
strong I mean okay of course white is is
an I am but I mean he's already a very
decent Grandmaster I mean he's waiting
is way above it is just one I think one
again and playing really really great
just be 594 well the thing is the bishop
is attacking and if something like this
this looks very vulnerable Knight g4
here white played really a beautiful
beautiful move I mean okay no not a very
easy one but he played a beautiful move
it looks like black has lots of feet
well technically it does have quite a
lot of pieces right now around the King
I mean the knight here the 90th the
Queen is even somewhat in the right
direction the bishop but that's why
White's next move is so so cool why play
this move
well attacking the rookies immediate but
all but more importantly this night is
way more important than the rukon d8 if
take here on f7 well then suddenly lots
of lots of pieces are open against
Blacks king I mean lots of lines let's
say mainly the G file I mean how is
black defending really everything here
doesn't really have a way here left
ladies move white took took so who is
the big defender for black in this
position the knight on e5 the knight is
defending g6 defending controlling many
many of the important squares ok take so
suddenly black is left with really just
the bishop and work rook is not that
great but some other pieces are not that
far away from the king I mean to be to
be precise they are not really that far
away form from the King okay I'll just
go back everything is great right I mean
when we are speaking in theoretical
terms but here white has a problem in
some way of course the first move that
we are thinking is going to be Queen
take g6 most logical move the problem is
with g7 and black is the first one to
actually to actually go after the King I
mean just winning here okay let's see
let's play here and win the Queen
probably this this is Tonga I mean let's
check check
and going to be checkmate right in
very very few moves doesn't really
matter so Quinn take these things
immediately is not working but it looks
like by far the most natural move that's
why that's why the night only five was
eliminated okay any ideas for white you
look f6 this is a decent idea
work f6 is decent idea [ __ ] of g6
before yeah that's another idea let's
start here
okay maybe blue maybe just just defect
actually actually I don't want to give
this pawn and if Bishop g7
then quintic
okay
and click windy ages and move that
atleast a very reasonable Norwalk f6
okay let let me go over g7
Tinku seven is reasonable I can I can
see and see if we all if there if
there's other I did take the pawn there
so there are so many pawns here that we
can take yeah this this is I was
thinking and then you wanna maybe take
on its take you right
okay maybe something like this okay I
just need to stop bringing defenders
like like like no joke like I mean you
know that's that's pretty much day our
topic like bringing defenders I mean
there may be some other lines moves that
I'm not seeing but okay week of six is
dangerous yeah just just a very very
primitive g5e strong enough yeah like
actually okay I look with a computer now
he says yeah Queen f7 is really strong
and like he's bringing defenders but
yeah this dis move that I was thinking
about it but okay just just prefer to
bring pieces after this move maybe not
very easy for y to break through yeah I
mean
so now queen take g6 okay woke up six
yeah g5 is kinda crashing but even just
bringing some defenders is a reasonable
possibility at least
mmm
No
no I thought I think maybe this is
something when F and F 1 is under attack
but but a lot a lot of a lot of really
know this this position is insanely
dangerous I mean ok why white why just
played crushing idea in one day game
quite immediately yeah I mean okay this
line that I this line is good enough
just taking Queen take Sifu I mean I
just don't want to blunt their big here
so far not doing that so that's kind of
good all right what
no but the work will take so Quinton g6
not working but what about this move
that was played well what what what is
is idea
exactly it's gonna be capturing on g6
with a check and he's taking control
over there g7 square right now that's a
really big move again not enough
defenders right now you know I don't I
didn't like the move g5 so much although
it was repeatedly the best move for
black I just want to bring defenders may
be inspired by the topic but okay look
g7 you see no no pieces around the King
and why just takes this pawn yeah it's
just gonna collect material I mean
something like this how is it going to
win here okay you know you tell me
I mean our topic is attack the king but
oh no what
um guys black man this is for you why to
play know his first name yes white no
King to well preferably eight servant
ff1 thinking that's about this no come
on I mean yes come on
like seriously no like in a bullet
pre-move without thinking yeah that and
the fear this is the move band on a play
that's a very cool
not if you yeah that's what they are
yeah that's what I always say good one
for white and if take so
why tis just till now there was some
simply tea
checkmate ideas here but no wait here we
go and these and okay no okay you just
played quite quite well I mean the
material is equal but black King looks
somewhat vulnerable yeah now a key idea
here is no defenders around the king
okay and why just went on in one I mean
well black actually doesn't have many
defenders around is king so always I
mean we're going to see three four more
examples you know just very simple you
know do that magic square see how many
pieces are there how many pieces are
aiming into that what are you're also
teaching about the magic square now okay
I thought you over you're impressed you
weren't okay then I have to improve
alright next game next game I need aha
next game is actually an interesting
game between one of the strongest women
player in the world and a message Chuck
against one of the strongest young
American twelve Cayden trove alright
okay Sicilian fast fast fast fast
no I'm going to speak much about this
one fast
taketake why it was actually much better
here
yeah yeah what she had to play something
better
yeah there was there was something quite
no actually yeah Castle maybe I mean
just because Queen take d6 hook take d6
is always so strong all right so they
got into this
Mamma Mia complicated position it was
actually interesting that there were
some lies you know you look with the
computer and it's suggesting some line
like I mean like DS yeah yeah that looks
very very human but no which game okay
so I will but we have this position this
is somewhat in our topic I mean actually
the game was black lost the game
immediately immediately and his key was
mama mia weak never
what do you done with which movies best
here you do know
okay so first let's see let's see how
the game continued would be three was
played attacking the Queen is a great
idea
and suddenly black is totally lost
because guess what you know how you want
to draw our magic square this okay not
so many pieces here if we take day it
not so many pieces and suddenly tiny bit
troubles everything is open dead kaput
bye-bye efore Bishop III any Queen e6
what is going to play someone
let's say who would exchange Queens here
who who think that why should exchange
Queens here excellent I would assume
that no one is sleeping and that you are
no one will actually exchange Queen see
that would be Wow
this is the King opponent King no like
plus bazillion like nothing like Bishop
c5 no like that's it
plus bazillion yeah so here yeah but
nothing I walked down to the two and a
half checks right I like it how he's
playing til check me pretty much yeah
beautiful but black at a super duper
cool move you that I would have never
found but that's why we have been here
not will be three what should it be
playing
but there's something in this madness of
this gentleman over there
this is the best move because i mean
it's it's super duper logical super
duper is an Israeli term like is the
Queen active yes the night but what is
that talk doing though nothing nothing
and this work is the one that's going to
fight the Queen on its only square so
we'll create was bringing a defender
bringing a piece to the game but I can
actually be better without this black
was like black just love the game
immediately immediately okay more
examples all right you know let's stay
with Anna Massey to cannot really be
that wrong I hey I was polite I said it
cannot be wrong you know she was playing
against the dude Duda like whom isn't
the team
okay so we are about here I think white
objectively should be better here but
it's Julian
correctly sees there aren't so many
pieces defending White's King so um
something to be careful if you are white
nothing around the King on the other
hand there also aren't many detective
pieces ever around White's King so it's
not like you need to keep all your army
like that and the opponent doesn't even
have one piece but potentially white
King can be well can we come under
attack this was played this was played I
mean it's all kind of logical rookie
three yeah look f1 seems natural in here
do you remember the game man beautiful
in here white black played and
believable move no seriously I mean what
white was okay why it was better but I
don't even remember exactly where was
the wrong moment but what if one looks
logical and so on but they played one
move here and white is just like lost
like like - for like it and no
unbelievable unbelievable
we need to the move okay
maybe
yeah computers say instead of who kept
on quintics before maybe but before
White Queen did I'll just say I mean
computers say that 22 was less this move
immediately really attacking this one
does make tiny bit sense and white is
better and now Queen fo is also a move
okay so we have Queen a for a move Queen
H to a move
okay let's go sit that's what a second
stopped let's say Queenie fall okay I
can play even here and so I shall can
also go by the way King g1 queen h2 I
will take the pawn can actually take the
pawn
maybe I cannot mama me I cannot take the
pawn then why didn't you tell me this
move but talking about what after but I
what after this evil move ya know tell
me also distress
mm-hmm
King f2 maybe walk take h3 but yeah
check checking ok fate is really strong
now so this is the threat and then
suggesting this way yeah but okay but
then something like that okay
no more attack I mean I want to go Queen
e5 and maybe maybe it's alright okay so
one more one more try here yeah that I
mean this is also better for black but
walk c8 okay fate maybe only move
then so amazing this retreat with the
book also also protecting protecting the
back rank everything that's it winning
resign over kaput no but amazing look
again
no no pieces no pieces here I mean like
we see this again and again and again
just no pieces around the King not to
get recommended not to get checkmated so
this was played not so great to defend
over there
me now how to win convincingly here
anyone other than Ben rookie one and
then if walk f1 which was very good so
tiny conclusion keeps keep some well
look at the square where your king is
and if you don't have any pieces around
there and your opponent start swinging
pieces start worrying this game was kind
of not really clear what White was
trying to do in this game but it's
really clear that what black was doing
for white just kind of kind of nasty
alright again we're gonna go quickly to
the opening whenever you play it Caden
many why in which tournaments this year
also
it's annoying when people in general
retail you know it's 2,000 no income on
like this year it's clear clear I meant
the last one the last tournament
seriously
you have a plus call okay good yeah we
2114 well I T apparently this is kind of
theory right they were banging mostly
like with no time like okay apparently
here this 20 minute thinking is not so
clear but we will go quickly
yeah I mean you know I was looking at
this position and it's actually no
objectively not so clear but it just
looks like really ugly for white but
okay well let's it vent tiny bit no
actually this sorry chill like life just
played every move like best computer
movie at some point like no it's kind of
stick but we got into this point all
right b5 I mean it's clear look when
looking at this position it's a bit it's
a bit tricky to figure out this position
because it looks like white at some
pressure here obviously as horrible pawn
structure and no okay horrible pawn
structure like everywhere you look and
like square what the bishops are quite
good the Knights are not occupying and
okay squares it and white needs like one
two moves I mean like h4 h5 and like
suddenly it's all all whites playing but
that's why went black plate is b5 no
okay so it's not it like white king it's
going to be like so safe and happy there
I mean we have before coming because
whites only defender around the skiing
or everything that hold it is the see
trippin
okay yeah here we played like a move
like dude do de do this ya know like I
mean really strong play this move okay
maybe just want to take the room but I
mean maybe he also has some other ideas
King h8 with the idea of just getting
this square and why does he want to get
this square this is a question why does
he want to get this square give me one
not you do you know 96 right so so then
that was this big idea it just wants to
be able to get the night now let's
forget for a second about the folk other
idea for white in this position because
well our topic today is not folks f3 our
topic today is not attacking weak pawns
okay so alright in what else
for what yes and diagonal did this
actually want the game but how before
and then what
so basically remove this spawn and then
attack this point
ah that this is exactly what we want to
do so King a one staying on the diagonal
I mean what is the next move like what
what what comes before a Ben yes I don't
know king alpha zero like I don't know
like it's going the diagonal okay before
no here we go I mean there's one thing
that's preventing white from collapsing
immediately and once this is gone
they're like really not so many pieces
around this King right I mean it's not
like who cares about these it's like
take
take yeah and like you know this this is
not not a very very pretty position like
you see this King know this this was
kind of ugly no been likes us such a
game is ugly yeah like you see their
books on the other side of the board
this bishop is like this is like just
being you know like killed many ways
here for white okay and black just went
on and one like you name it
but again okay it was maybe more office
structure point but again they collapse
the immediate collapse was not because
actually material
no pieces around the king at all the
last game that I will show is actually
from the egg group regarding this
exactly this topic and okay they
actually actually there were some
tactics before that that plans could
have played a bit better sleep all day
party all night in the morning that's
what you do in the morning
hmm Ben and Friends you know like a TV
show so he looks kind of dangerous here
and like here it's amazing what is the
which movies best I would never never
never imagined this move but it's like
really big advantage no King it is easy
I would play that with no no I think if
anyone okay its Queen d2 I will never
play this movie
why just even now I don't understand the
idea that's if I'm right don't remember
no but I mean but like just exchanging
here it's like stain no the King is
dangerous motoki we will go tiny bit
further no but but there was a better
move
maybe maybe Bishop d2 I don't remember
but the amazing part is that even
without the Queen's this is still
incredibly dangerous like incredibly I
mean back to our you know beautiful
square just a bit show up so many weak
spots like just we king I mean okay this
week King actually got really checkmated
like really checkmated yeah this is
actually a wank move a wrong move no
computer for whatever reason suggesting
DS and G foe in like huge plus we are
not going to dramatically analyze it but
really big plumbing I think on Houdini
like plus two and they have something
like like really really forget about it
yes oh and after this move after yeah
that actually was kind of complicated
yet mere anything it's exactly know the
thing is that even I mean this again
we're not analyzing this much but even
without the Queen's amazing and in the
toilet you can also maybe make effort to
do it in in a computer not easy but
bottom line somehow no okay maybe here
night I'm not going to analyze it too
much all I want to show is this King
scary scary and actually here
no just okay that's what happened to the
king what happened after Luke g8 okay
just winning the night yeah saving the
night but when when your king get
checkmated here it's not so pretty
I play this preventing over seven out
out
no okay we could have of course
analyzing seen this game much much
slower but blessed you but basically
again simplest ideas you know don't
forget pieces around your king many
people just well they remember it when
they are checkmated so like you know
those are really strong players I mean
not as strong as me and Ben but still
strong players in the a well in the a
tournament I mean even in the B
tournament many very decent grandmasters
in there were quite a lot of games there
that well just the Kings were like
totally naked and bang bang they were
kind of dead
that's something for today remembering
our King and everything or whatever is
around